indian infrastructure mogul goda madani
became the richest asian billionaire in
history earlier this month and he's kept
on climbing adani has now passed warren
buffett to become the fifth richest
person in the world forbes estimates
that the 59 year old adani has a net
worth of 123 123.7 billion dollars as of
friday's market close edging out the
121.7 billion dollar fortune of buffett
who is 91. adani is the founder and
chairman of adani group a port and
energy conglomerate with six publicly
traded companies in india
shares of each of those businesses are
up between 19 and 195 percent this year
as adani has led aggressive expansion
into renewable energy media airports and
more earlier this month abu dhabi's
international holding company invested
two billion dollars in three of adani's
green energy focused firms he has said
he wants to become the world's largest
producer of green energy with a goal of
investing up to 70 billion dollars into
renewable energy projects the son of a
textile merchant adani dropped out of
college and in 1988 started a
commodities export firm by 2008 he had
become a billionaire joining the forbes
ranks for the first time worth an
estimated 9.3 billion dollars his
fortune really began to take off at the
start of the covet 19 pandemic after
expanding his empire with major
acquisitions like the 2020 purchase of a
74 stake in mumbai international airport
india's second busiest
in april adani agreed to buy ocean
sparkle india's largest marine services
company in a 220 million dollar deal
adani's estimated
123.7 billion net worth makes him the
richest person in india he surpasses
buffett as shares of the famed investors
berkshire hathaway dropped by two
percent last week amid a broad drop in
the u.s stock market there are now only
four people on the planet richer than
adani according to forbes real-time
billionaire tracker bill gates bernard
arnaud jeff bezos and elon musk